what's up believe Nations I started to
mentor me serious with the goal to hang
your own people who have done a lot more
than us who've been a lot more
successful am i spending a little more
time with them hopefully some of their
mindset their views their beliefs
keeping to us to help us become the best
version of ourselves so today we're
going to learn from sundar pichai and
his road to becoming the CEO of Google
mentor me sundar and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you see
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and if you write it down
it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the thing which attracted me to Google
and to Internet in general is that it's
a great equalizer right and so to me
always being struck by the fact that
Google search work the same little if as
long as you had access to computer with
connectivity you were a rule kid
anywhere or if you were a professor at
Stanford or Harvard and and to me you
know I want Google to strive to push to
do that not just build technology for a
certain segments right for me it's it
matters that you know we drive
technology as an equalizing force as an
enabler to everyone around the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what motivated you to switch fields from
first metallurgy you management to
computer science and did you ever feel
incompetent or even a bit insecure while
working with people who were given more
of qualifying match field than you would
you know my my background you know I was
always interested technology and you
know the first chance I could get to
program I learned programming and you
know so for me I never thought of it as
switching fields as much as when the
internet started happening you know you
know it took me a while to realize the
power of it and you know you know it
became obvious to me for the first time
we are going to have something which
could you know connect one day all of
humanity and would profoundly transform
what people did so I wanted to be a part
of that so you know part of the journey
so that's always thought of it and
sudden think of it as Netflix switching
carriers would actually encourage all of
you you know it's at some point in your
life you know you have to work with
people where you feel a bit insecure
like that's essential because that means
you're working with people who are
better than you and we're pushing you
right and so always encourage if you if
you actually feel very secure in what
you do you know that means you're doing
something comfortable and you're not
pushing yourself and so there are many
many times
working with people in a group am i
doing enough these people seem much
better than me and I think I think
that's a inherent part of learning you
know I interviewed I interviewed at
Google on April 1st 2004 which is April
Fool's Day and Google had just announced
Gmail and you know it was invite only
and so you know but people weren't
exactly sure that it was a April Fool's
joke and you know so I remember doing my
interviews during the day and people
kept asking me what do you think of
Gmail but you know I hadn't had a chance
to use it I thought they were you know
it was a April Fool's joke
so my first three interviews I couldn't
answer it well because I didn't use the
product there's only in the fourth
interview and someone asked me have you
seen Gmail I said no and so he actually
showed it to me and then the 15th of
your ass what do you think of Gmail and
I was able to start answering it them so
the final four interviews I actually
told them about you know what I think of
Gmail and how to improve Gmail and
that's that's my interview experience
like somebody in the middle also took me
to have ice cream in the middle which
showed me Google is a very very
different place as well so that was
online in 3 percent well is it true that
everyone at that time was interviewed by
Larry Page is that you know I was one of
the first people I think you know I
joined Google when we were over a
thousand people and Larry just at that
point was the first time see it stopped
interviewing people I still joke around
that I got into Google Larry didn't
interview me
I did dream of just like I'm sure like
many many Indians terms of being a
cricketer you know used to be a huge
high history I used to be a huge fan of
thorium all but I used to be huge fan of
the Lasker you know when he was playing
and I'm later on such and when he played
but you know so always you know had a
dream honor on a more serious note you
know I always loved technology growing
up and you know so I had dreams of just
not exactly what I would do but I wanted
to you know at the time you don't need
to read about what was happening in
Silicon Valley and you know I wanted to
go be a part of it so I didn't exactly
dream a carrier as much as a destination
you're sitting in I he could have put in
a room that wasn't quite as fancy as
this hole is and there is no Google so
how are you keeping in touch with what
Silicon Valley is doing and how are you
dreaming wow I have to think about that
permanent there was no internet to and
you know it was pre all that you know
mostly reading and you know my uncle had
gone to the states and you know so and
you know was interested in in
semiconductors and so on and William
Shockley the person who and I invented
semiconductors you know was from Silicon
Valley so I've read a story about him
staying you know working - at Stanford
close to Christmas Eve and subscribe
like that so you know also what I was
interested in I knew that that's I was
happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but what is sundar Pichai like as a
leader you know I think religion style
now when you're when you're trying to
run something at the scale of Google you
know we have now over 60,000 people and
you know I rely on other strong leaders
I think in a lot of what I do is you
know I have an outstanding leadership
team and learning to let go and really
empowering people you know at all levels
of the organization and you know
trusting them to do doing the right
thing and as a leader a lot of your job
is to make those people successful it's
less less about trying to be successful
and more about making sure you have good
people and your your work is to remove
that barriers remove roadblocks for them
so that they can be successful in what
they do and so that's how I've always
thought about it and I've also valued
you know teamwork quite a bit and you
know I think it's really important to
build all the organizations where people
actually want to work together yeah you
know everything comes out of that so
setting up collaborative cultures kind
of a big thing I try to focus on so it's
what about one courses about the team
that's right and if your team succeed
you ought to succeed with it
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know I would you know would really
encourage people to you know I think
there's a lot of pressure in today's
system you know I I get surprised people
start preparing for IIT in their eighth
grades and man oh that's that's a bit
shocking to me you know I I hope you
know I hope you know you know as people
are approaching things they are really
taking the time to doing things you know
in a deeper way you know understanding
things deeper learning by doing things
and you know I think it's important to
remember it's a long road setbacks
actually don't matter you know I think a
lot of times when I was younger you know
people would say you know this person
didn't get into this college or
something and that's the end of the road
I mean life is so different from that
and so I think it's important to you
know keep your hopes keeps you keep your
dreams and try to follow them and you
know I think I think most of how life
plays out is up to you not up to up to
what happens outside of you and I think
it's important to keep that in mind and
take the long-term view thank you guys
so much for watching I love to know what
did you think what did you learn from
sundar today that's going to have the
biggest impact on your life or your
business what was your favorite clip and
why leave it down the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
julio Velez julio thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and for making that book summary
video on your YouTube channel I really
really really appreciate your support
today's book is called your one-word by
Evan Carver kill so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you soon